grunts was just just an answer mm well
you're not really you're saying
something yeah they're not actually
words I don't know that's that's an
interesting question because I think
that again that guy that I recorded that
belched all of his answers and each I
mean you could tell what he was saying
with the belch you know that it was the
same belch but you go okay he agrees oh
he doesn't like that at all with belches
and the thing about stuff like that is I
mean you you tread water into getting
into the acting side where you want
actors to be able to sort of come up
with some of those things themselves so
you may I don't know there's there's a
place where writing stops and
performance begins and I would be
basically if I were in that situation I
would figure out the yes/no version of
that character and then let the actor
figure it out which gets to like Riley's
parentheticals and scripts where you
know you should I don't believe in
telling an actor how to act because
actors have it's their talent so the
example that I was used is there's a the
remake of The Killers by Don Siegel
there's a scene where Lee Marvin who's
one of the killers is questioning this
guy and if basically saying if you don't
tell me this information I'm going to
smash your heads in an auto garage thing
you know I'm going to smash your head
into that clamp I'm going to do this and
it's all this violent stuff and you just
know that you know it's like screaming
or whatever in parentheticals except Lee
Marvin as the actor went up to him put
his arm around and said you know you
know give me this information I'm gonna
have to take that wrench over there and
slam it into your head so you should
tell us to me they should tell it to me
right now and basically took what was an
obvious scene with you no yelling or
screaming or threatening and turned it
into a totally different scene by
basically coming it all down and
whispering that's so much better scene
because that actor gave that performance
the dialogue they say is still the same
but I
I don't think we should tell actors how
to act you know let them do their own
thing you know I don't know how that
deals with the belching and the grunting
you